Hi everyone, I'm Chris
Broadfoot.
Welcome to this week's Google
Maps Developer Shortcut.
I'm going to show you how to
get started with the Google
Maps Android API in under
five minutes.
I've just released a project
called How I Map Android.
It's on github.com/googlemaps.
Go ahead and check out
the repository.
Now you could take a fork of it
if you wanted, or you can
download the zip file
if that's easier.
All of them's good.
If I scroll down here, you can
see there's instructions in
more detail.
But follow along with
this video.
So if I go into the directory,
you can see that all the files
are checked out.
Now you can use Eclipse,
IntelliJ, or Ant, they're all
fine and will work.
First I'll show you
how to import the
project into Eclipse.
I'm going to use a brand new
workspace just to make sure
that everything's clean, and
we're going to go and import
that project there, and
run the hellomap.
So File, Import, you want to
import an existing Android, go
and choose the directory, press
Open, make sure that
both of those check boxes are
clicked, press finish.
I'm not sure what that is, but
I think it'll still work.
If I close the perspective and
reopen the Java perspective,
we'll see all of our files.
Close that one.
So the most important file
here, immediately, is the
Androidmanifest.xml.
Now you're going to have to go
and add you API key down here,
I'll show you how to do
that in just a moment.
I'll show you quickly how
to import into IntelliJ.
On the home screen, press Open
Project, or you can go File,
Open Project.
Once again, navigate
to the project.
Press choose.
It's going to open up.
Now the first thing you'll
have to do is to add the
Android SDK to the project
definition.
So you can do that by going
File, Project Structure, and
choose your Android SDK here.
Now, if you don't have them
there already, you can go New,
Android SDK.
Set that all up.
It's very easy.
Press OK.
If I go into project, you can
see all the files here again.
Androidmanifest.xml, it's
very important.
Now to run the project, we're
going to have to go into Edit
Configurations.
Press the plus sign, Android
application, choose the
hellomap module.
We want a USB device.
You can't use an emulator to run
Android maps applications.
Go ahead and press OK.
I've forgotten the module,
the hellomap module.
Press OK, make sure your phone
is plugged in and unlocked.
Now head over to the Google
API's console.
You'll have to create a new
project, enable the Android
API in there, the Android
maps API.
Head over to API access, and
create a new Android key.
There's instructions on how to
get your debug key store
certificate in here, and you'll
want to make sure
you're using the
com.example.hellomap package.
Now go ahead and take your key,
put it into your Android
manifest, hit Run in Eclipse
or IntelliJ, Ant works just
fine as well.
And you'll see a map
on your phone.
That's it, enjoy your Android
maps development experience,
and I'll see you next time.